what's up everybody zacky here with
another fantastic video this time we
have a sweet sweet collection of new and
exciting chibi vinyl figure ubi
collectibles
these chibi figurines celebrate all the
characters from your favorite ubisoft
games and we are going to unbox all of
them
and shout out to the awesome guys at
ubisoft singapore for sending these to
us
and if you want to know where to get
them as well as more details link in the
description below
with that's it let's get to it here we
have four new figures as part of the ub
hero series one featuring ezio auditory
from assassin's creed
nomad from ghost recon breakpoint a fan
favorite vast figure from falcare3
and of course this rabbit inspired from
sam fisher in splinter cell and of
course the rabbit in raving rabbits
so
let's unbox this shall we
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
on top of that we've got two exclusive
figures that are not available here in
singapore which are the eagle vision
etio as well as the hawaiian themed vars
so let's check this out
[Music]
[Applause]
so there you have it the ub heroes
series 1 collectibles so let's move on
to the rainbow six siege collectibles
and of course we have the rainbow six
siege series five and other bonus
figures
like this reskin the chunker from series
with the red star and white face paint
and this
golden
castle
very nice
so the series 5 figures will have
dock
gridlock
castle and alibi so let's go ahead and
unboxing
[Music]
and for every rainbow six figure you
guys do get unlockable coats so this
one's for you guys
there we go
grab them while you can
[Music]
and of course the bonus items so
the golden
castle
[Music]
and last but not least we've got
the
a chunker
to chunker
[Music]
so that's it for the rainbow six siege
series five
figurines as well as the the chunka
series one well that's it for the
unboxing the ubi heroes collectible
chibi figures are already available at
the ubisoft official shop on shopee
singapore
if you enjoyed this unboxing do give us
a like and share if you haven't already
do consider subscribing for more epic
unboxings reviews and more
let us know in the comments below which
is your favorite figure and until then
this is zacky signing off
[Music]
you